this is Picasso a Senegalese parrot due  to their popularity they are one of the  most heavily trapped birds in the world  spread throughout western Africa they  live in open woodlands and savannas and  feed on fruit seeds buds and  occasionally crop items Senegalese  parrots are only about 9 inches long and  weigh up to 6 ounces they may be small  in size but they are a gag arias Bunch  with lively energetic personalities  their dark grey faces are complemented  by green and yellow plumage across their  body Senegalese parrots are incredibly  popular pets which has made the trade  import and export of wild court parrots  illegal this is the Senegalese Paris  [Music]